- [Instructor] We have four
triangles depicted here,
and they've told us that the triangles
are not drawn to scale.
And we are asked which two
triangles must be congruent?
So pause this video, and
see if you can work this out
on your own before we work
through this together.
All right, now let's work
And it looks like for every one of these
or actually almost every one of these,
they've given us two angles,
and they've given us a side.
This triangle IJH, they've
only given us two angles.
So what I'd like to do is,
if I know two angles of a triangle,
I can figure out the third
angle because the sum
of the angles of a triangle
have to add up to 180 degrees.
And then I can use that information,
maybe with the sides that they give us,
in order to judge which of
these triangles are congruent.
So first of all, what is
going to be the measure
of this angle right over here,
the measure of angle ACB?
Pause the video, and
try to think about that.
Well, one way to think about it,
if we call the measure of that angle x,
we know that x plus 36
plus 82 needs to be equal to 180.
I'm just giving their
measures in degrees here.
And so you could say x plus,
let's see 36 plus 82 is 118.
Did I do that right?
Six plus two is eight,
and then three plus eight is 11.
Yep, that's right.
So that's going to be equal to 180.
And then if I subtract
118 from both sides,
I'm going to get x is equal to,
180 minus 18 is 62.
So this is x is equal to 62,
or this is a 62-degree angle,
I guess is another way
of thinking about it.
I could put everything in
terms of degrees if you like.
All right, now let's do the same thing
with this one right over here.
Well, this one has an 82-degree
angle and a 62-degree angle,
just like this triangle over here.
So we know that the third
angle needs to be 36 degrees,
36 degrees.
Because we know 82 and 62,
if you need to get to
180, it has to be 36.
We just figured that out from
this first triangle over here.
Now, if we look over
here, 36 degrees and 59,
this definitely looks like
it has different angles,
but let's figure out what
this angle would have to be.
So if we call that y degrees,
we know, I'll do it over here,
y plus 36 plus 59
is equal to 180.
And I'm just thinking in
terms of degrees here.
So y plus,
this is going to be
equal to, what is this?
This is going to be equal to 95,
is equal to 180.
Did I do that right?
Yep, that's 80 plus 15, yep, 95.
And then if I subtract 95 from both sides,
what am I left with?
I'm left with y is equal to 85 degrees.
And so this is going to
be equal to 85 degrees.
And then this last
triangle right over here,
I have an angle that has a measure of 36,
another one that's 59.
So by the same logic,
this one over here has to be 85 degrees.
So let's ask ourselves,
now that we've figured out
a little bit more about these triangles,
which of these two must be congruent?
So you might be tempted
to look at these bottom
two triangles and say,
hey, look all of their
angles are the same.
You have angle, angle, angle
and angle, angle, angle.
Well, they would be similar.
If you have three angles
that are the same,
you definitely have similar triangles.
But we don't have any length
information for triangle IJH.
You need to know at
least one of the lengths
of one of the sides in
order to even think,
start to think about congruence.
And so we can't make any
conclusion that IJH and LMK,
triangles IJH and triangles LMK
are congruent to each other.
Now let's look at these
candidates up here.
We know that their
angles are all the same,
and so we could apply angle,
I'll do this in a different color,
angle, side, angle,
36 degrees, length six, 82 degrees,
36 degrees, length six,
82 degrees.
So by angle, side, angle,
we know that triangle ABC
is indeed congruent to triangle DEF.
And we're done.